*shits pants
*
MAMMA MIA
*screams again like a man*
JESUS
Heeey- He- *coughs*
Heey how's it going Bros my name is
PEEWDIEPIE
Welcome
Welcome welcome welcome malcom
To Resident Evil 7 playthrough
Oh, it's been a while since we've done one of these
'Cuz I was waiting for this one
T- to come out
Resident Evil
One of the pinnacles of the survival horror  ge- gaming ge- genre
Sorta went downhill for a while didn't it?
Just like it's brother Silent Hill
Where did it all go wrong?
Could it be that big publishers care more about making (money)
Than really about making horror games?
Could it be that indie games has made a push back for horror games
And show that they can be quite successful?
It seem like finally
Finally
Resident Evil is back to where it should be
At its core
At the horror
I dunno why I'm talking like I have something stuck up my ass like I
I- I am genuinely passionate about these things and
I'm really excited
To see
Where this game is going
I'm very excited to be sharing this with you and
We're gonna finish this game together
It's gonna be a lot of fun
I hope you're into horror games as much as I am
If not maybe you will be after this
And without further ado
Let's play this video game
I will go on normal
Despite the fact that I probably shouldn't
But hey, sometimes you gotta live hard and
This doesnt seem like one of those moments actually
I don't know
It's probably gonna lead to you being pissed off at me
For not being good at-
WOOAH "Hello baby!" JESUS CHRIST
"I just wanted to send a quick 'Hello'" UGH
"and I love you."
"OH! Good news! I'm gonna be comming home soon. Yay!"
SHOOT HER
"Ohh. "  KILL THE- Ugh
"I cannot wait" Not so close "to be done with this baby sitting job"
"and come home to my loving husband."
Oh mY GOD IT IS a nightmare
"I miss you"
A TRUE horror
"Ahh I gotta get back to work."
"I love you Ethan, I miss you so much, I'm sending tons of kisses."
*kiss*
EWGHH "Bye baby!"
*Gag reflex*
*Vomits*
Aww Ethan
*I'm Ethan Bradberry!*
That would be the real plot twist of this game if we're playing as Ethan
Oh shi- dude what the fuck?
"Ethan,"
Okay
"Ngh,"
"You were right."
"I did lie to you."
"I shouldn't have-" *Pewds exits to menu* I am really sorry I'm hearing clipping
And I'm really worried that you guys are as well
So I'm gonna make sure
Sorry about that
Should be fine
"All I can say is that,"
"If you get this-"
DO NOT
"-STAY AWAY."
Okay
You know what?
Game over *giggles*
This is pretty cool so far
I know it's just the cutscene but it's very- y
It's beyond my expectations
*Buttons beeping sound*
I've been trying really hard not to hype myself up for this game
*Calling sound*
"Hello?" It's very cinematic isn't it? "Hey, it's uh.."
"It's Ethan""Oh hey!"
It's Ethan "You alright?"
"You just disappeared the other night."
"Yea-, yea I know I'm good, I'm good"
It's gorgeous
"It's Mia.."
"She's not dead, she's alive. She- she's back"
"They found her?"
"How? What happened? "
"I don't know."
"Look. I don't know how.. but she's back."
"She's back somehow."
"Maybe it's a prank.." Holy shit
"She wants me to come and get her."
"Where is she?" that looks incredible is this a movie?
"Dulvey. Dulvey, Louisiana."
"Dude, it's been 3 years."
"I know. I know, but.. What if it is her? "
"I have to find out what happened."
Um.. I'm just gonna go and guess - make a wild guess
She's fucking dead
3 years gone? Na-ah they're always dead
Horror rule N.45
Uuuhm
They never let you edit these sorta things
While y- before you begin
So I'm sorry for doing this
But
Here we go
Now you can't bitch about me talking too much
A retry already?
It does look pre-rendered, doesn't it?
I'm very impressed though
I am like- I'm getting super hyped right now
Looking at this
What the fuck?
Okay
I'm moving around
I'm looking around
This is the place
This is the place to be
With my car, I like the car
Very nice car
I'm talking a lot, I'm getting a little nervous
I dunno why
This fucking brought day light
It's just woods fucking scaring me
And mosquitos
Fuckin hell
Are we in Australia? What is this place?
This is- OH MY GOD THAT'S THE HOUSE FROM THE GAME
Check your objective
How?
Find Mia
THANKS GAME
So what the fuck is this?
Email from Mia
We have a printout of the email
You can't print
I suppose you we can
Uh-huh
Okay
This is so fucking cool
I can run?
I heard that you don't have a gun in this one
We'll see if that's true or not
I don't think that's ever been done in Resident Evil game
Okay, well that's not gonna work is it?
I suppose we can climb over?
Oh- sorry my-
I got a new controller it's pretty cool but
I can't fucking use it
Jesus
Why don't I just
So I don't make y'all motion sick or whatever
Why don't I just adjust that really quick
You can tell you're new to controllers
If you fucking play on two
There we go
That's smoother
Just hate watching let's plays when
The fucking head goes like EWUEEHH
I dunno why I always try the same things
I think I have a problem
Alright we need to find Mia
Okay what would I do in this situation?
I mean I wouldnt be in this situation cuz I'm a puss
Okay, and we can't enter the bushes
Maybe there's a path that we didn't really see
There it is
No this is where we came from
Great, you're a fucking genius Pewds
So our girlfriend
I guess, was babysitting
And then she got just
Went away- OOH HEllo
This is Mia's car
Oh is this the film crew from the demo?
IT IS
Ha ha
Did you check out the demo?
You play as like this film crew
It's very cool
That's supposed to tripod-
Sewer Gators
Okay
Join us
No thank you paper
But I appreciate the invite
Okay
Very cool
Accept her gift
I will as long as it's her pussey
I am so sorry
I can't help it
I may have Tourette's
I am- I need to look into it
I know it's not funny
And I know
I dunno- yea uh it's okay
OH MY GOd that's a guy
I think I'll fuck off for now
Especially because he's bald
I don't trust bald people
I'm sorry I have a prejudice against you if you're bald
I probably won't go near you
Where the fuck did that guy go?
Was that Tarzan?
The hell is this place?
I'll look over here it looks prettier
HEY BALD MAN
WHERE'D YOU- oh shit
What?
What is this?
Ohh-
OH
JESUS
Jesus
Well first jump scare of the game thank you ve-
Bald man turned into a dead cow
What a mystery
Oh my god
It is beautiful
Wh wow
OH WOW NOW I SEE WHAT IT IS
*laughs*
EEH
HA
WHY THANK YOU FOR- EH
Thank you for the gift honey
Awh my god
It's so pretty
Ya know
When you see something like that
That's generally like a good way to be like
You know what?
Is this g- is this bitch worth it?
I would be like
Mmmm
*Sizziling noise*
Aaahh
*More sizziling noise*
Aaaaaaaaaaaaarghh
I don't think so
I mean I would for Marzia
But I wouldn't call Marzia
That would be weird
Okay
It's all jokes
Everyone calm down
Hey crows
How's- how's it going Bros - crows am I right?
AAAAH
ITS POOODIEPIE
Yep
That's me
Alright
We got a silo and shit
And we enter the point of no return
WOOP
Aargh
Hey we did it
High five Bro
*high five*
Well haven't you missed these moments?
I miss when PewDiePie played games
Because he- he high fives me
And it makes me feel good
'Cuz I have no friends
He- no
I didn't say that
HEY, could that be Mia?
What did it say? I didn't really
Get to look at it
No
Aah you fucking
Jesus Christ
It's a Texas drivers' license (hey i'm from der)
And it doesn't say
Anything 'cuz it's in Texas (whats that suppossed to mean pewds??)
Winters
Could that be her surname?
I suppose
What is happening?
I did like a quick turn I didn't mean to do that
Okay
Back and circle, that's a quick turn
That might be useful
Alright
So this is the house that you played on in the demo
Except it's daylight, which is kinda interesting how they
They're building tension, ya know?
I like it
That's how you do horror games man
A lot of people forget about it
Tension
It's fucking important
Okay
An open door
This is where I escaped in the demo
I believ- I'm sorry I'll stop referring to the fucking demo
We're playing the real shit here
Hello?
Ooh
Who closed the fucking door?
Dat
Dat is another big warning sign(damn right Poods)
Just so I feel safe I'm gonna check if I can open the-
Nawh
Oh hell nawh
*Loud sigh*
Alraight
We can do this( o really?)
It's you and the man
This is honestly the reason I started recording youtube
It's because I was too scared to play horror games(as if we didn't know that,Poods)
By myself
I thought it made more sense if I just film myself 'cuz then I feel less lonely
Is that- is that sad?(Yes it is...Poods..)
Okay it's fine
Ya know what?
I've been in here before
It shouldn't be an-*noise*
Aw mai gawd
What was that?
It shouldn't be any problem
Mia?
Is this where you've been living in?
Select an item
Well none of these is gonna help(ain't dat obvious)
So
We need to find like a bolt cutter or some shit
What a lovely place
*Laughs*
Honestly you could shape this place up this place could be nice
HEEY
Microwaved
Crows
My favorite
They taste
Crunchy
Why do I bother che-
EEEW
EEW
EW
CLOSE IT
UGHH
Disgusting
*Almost throws up*
It's so detailed
What the fuck
Ooh
Uugh
Okay we got something here
Over 20 missing in 2 years
Ghost sighted in
Bayou
Great name of a city
Okay
Is there someone upstairs?
I don't like how defenseless I am
There's something blinking upstairs
Oh my god
I can't tell if this is like a prologue or some shit
Where this is just gonna
Kill me and then it's gonna be like MEAAAM
And then it's gonna start off with another character kinda
Okay I don't know
I don't know
Okay I'm just specualting and I don't
I'm just don't wanna run if shit gets bad
I don't like it
Well is anyone here?
Oh that's a creepy fucking picture
What the hell is up with her face?
Oh more creepy-
Ahh f- fucks s-
God damn it
Here's the fuses okay
We don't have one
But if I find a fuse
I'll play the piano
*Sings*
*Totally not fake scream*
*Laughs*
Oh and you can play the VHS yea
Okay
Alright
Insteresting
*noise*
What the fuck was that
We know there is something in the furnace
But we can't
I guess this guy technically doesn't know
Looks like the owners
Wow
Then look like they have a great time
That dad looks so done with life
Basically me
Am I right?
Relateable - brofist
Okay
Alright
I think
I think we're gonna have to go upstairs
I really didn't wanna go upstairs
'Cuz in every fucking horror movie ever
They die when they go upstairs
Now I'm not keen on dying, alright?
Not today at least
So
Fuck
Just not
Just OH
Fuck
The shadow fucking scared me
Jesus Christ
Okay
Keep the fucking
Jesus Christ
I don't like this
Hey what a lovely photo of me
I remember that
*Laughs*
Okay
What is th-
They want me to look there
Huh? I know your tricks games
Stairs
So you can make the stairs go upstairs?
Wow
That's a
That's a new one
*Laughs*
Okay- OH VHS tape
I'll take that
WOW YOU SAVE ON THOSE
I LOVE WHEN GAMES DO THAT
It's like those old RPG games
Like you talk to a cat
Now you saved
Cool
Alright
We got something
Let's go down
Not too bad
Not too bad so far
Now I underst- OH this wasn't here before
Was it?
Or was it? I don't know
Maybe someone just took a shit in that drawer while I was down
It's called the toilet
Alright then
Let's play this baby
Hopefully it's not a Jacksepticeye video
Ain't nothing worse than that shit
Ah here we go
I imagine it's the film crew
Vh-
js
Dulvey Hounted House - rehearsal
WOOOW Jesus
We've seen this
Aah fuck we gotta play this
DudE I CAN FUCKING HEAR YOU
MWEEH
Hey
I'm fucking PooDiePie
I'm the star
Alright here we go
I guess I'm the camera guy?
Heey I'm getting great angles here buddy
Trust me the Sewer Gators
Fans are gonna love this
Ohh yeah
Aah no
Okay
You may wanna
Get out of the
Just kick it in
I go first
This guy is really errmmm they're professionals
Aww dude the food looks delicious
Aaw woow
What do you mean the usual?
Who?
Lucas huh?
*Laughs*
This guy's voice is so fucking annoying
Okay I'm filming
Yep doing it
That looks- this is
Your angle
Oh fuck he dissapeared
Andre
Aaw you aah
God fucking a dammit
Hey my name is Poodie
Y'know fuck you I'm going upstairs
I'm doing this only because i've played the demo and I know what's gonna happen
I'm kinda curious what happens if you just go fucking upstairs
I suppose nothing
*Laughs*
Okay
Alright sorry
My curiosity got the better of me
I wonder if the shit hole thing-
It's still there huh? Okay
Well guess
He likes to take his shits there
Yeah I- shh
This guy is the fucking worst Jesus Christ
I mean if Andre is tha producers he's doing a good job at-
Ya know?
Fuck this
I dont know what's gonna happen tho
I don't remember
*Sigh*
Oh yea see I remember this that's- oh
What?
Yea so don't go in there
More like uh
We can just go
Andre was- oh, hello
Damn those jeans tho
Woah what the fuck is that?
Oh it's just baskets
Alright you go first my man
Hey good friend you go first better angle
Trust me
Ha
The hero shot huh?
Alright
*laughs*
Aaaalrigth yea let's look at the hero
Awwh fuck it's all wet dude
Your mom's down here
That's why it smells *goteem*
Come on buddy
Come on
Wait are you serious I have to look?
OOOH
FUCK
What is this f-
Andre?
EEEW EWWGH ANDRE AAAAANDREE
God fucking damn it, dude!
Wow, what a great movie, I really enjoyed that one
*Giggles*
And that's my clue, to get the fuck out huh
How about that?
Just realized I have an appointment
Fucking hell
Alright
So I suppose now we know where to go
Interesting
Kind of advanced for a shitty house like this but
I suppose it's just aged a lot
Ah God fuck
Now were going down
Okay
Alright
I wore my good shoes Jesus Christ
These are italian leather
Man
Va-Fanculo! *italian for "fuck"*
Jesus Christ
Ooh what the fuck who made tha ladder? *Italian accent*
I don't like where this is going
Not one fucking bit Bros
I'm gonna be quite honest with you right now
Hellow *high pitched*
Sorry
Hello- hello?
UH
What is that?
Ah it's just water
Okay it's just water
It's just water
Ain't no water ever killed anyone
Unless lack of water counts
Aaah
Awh sh-
*Spits*
Got in my mouth
*Spits again*
Ohh f-
Why am I so- UGH
What was that?
Sorry I'm on fucking edge Jesus Christ
Hello?
Hello hello okay
The faster we can get out of here the faster i can go home- WAH
Wait i can cover my face?
N- AHHH
NO
NOO
It's alright I just farted actually it's fine
You can tell in the- it stank
You can tell
Cuz I already- AH
Sorry
Okay
I'm fine
I'm fucking fine
Everything is fucking fine
AAAHHH
JESUSS!
WE'RE NOT FINE
AW IT'S ANDRE EW
DISGUSTING
DIsgusting
Disgusting
Get away
Get the fuck away from me
Ewh
Ewwwwh
Aahh
Dis-
Ugh
Fuck my life
This girl is not worth it
Alright? This is j- she's not
I'm sorry
Hello?
You got me all wet and disgusting
Alright
Who's
Running the
Who's running this place
Oh we saw this cell before in a picture
Oh my god
Aah fuck
Okay we're fine
Everyone is fine
There's no reason to be upset
I am a little bit upset
*loud noise*
Okay what have we got?
Fucking pussy *In Swedish*
Who keeps fucking doing that?
Alright so we have a happy family
An ananan that says sorry daddy daddy
Daddy do daddy do
Heey they- they- they have a toilet
What's the fucking problem
Okay
What if Mia is here?
That'd be interesting
*pewds panics*
Okay
Mia?
Mamma Mia?
*Song words*
Oh my god
This is bad
This is very not good
Bado
It's a very- bolt cutters
WHAT DID I FUCKING SAY AT THE START
Alright we got Ben  - dead
Harold - turned
Arthur - turned
Zombies, Tamara
Okay
What about Mia?
What about mamma Mia?
Mia Mia Mia Mia Mia Mia
I dont see a Mia
Do you guys see a Mia?
I don't fucking see a Mia (Pewds it's at the top)
Am I crazy? (do u really want the answer?)
Guess there's-
Okay well *facepalm*
pls
Maybe that's a good thing I don't know
Doing some investigations
I suppose we could technically go back
But...
Oh my god.
I don't like this.
Okay.
Let's use the bolt cutters on the lock
I suppose
I don't
I don't feel very good
Mia
You better not be dia
As in dead
i just said it cuz it rhymes
I would hold- hang on to those bolt cutters if I were you
Mia do not fucking jumpscare me
I swear to god
ETHAN BRADBERRY
You don't look too bad
Yea you said not to come
It's kinda awkward
Ahh fuck
Okay
We're going
Daddy but I'm your daddy ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Right?
That's
I mean you can call me whatever you want
Sorry
Just- let's just go
Let's just go
We can talk- we can catch up later
It's fine
Y- you just go
I'll make sure this side is safe
And if
Anyone
Arrives
What?
What are you doing?
Fucking hell you're gonna fucking throw me off jesus
I guess
You know what?
I said she would be dead
And I was wrong
And you know what?
I wanna apologize
Okay
Hey
Hey hey hey
Cables
Not cables
Anything but
Why- oh god what is that?
Oh what are those?
What are those?
WHAT ARE THOSE?
They don't look good
*Wtf gag or something?*
Sorry I'm a little
Its' a trap
It's a trap
Fuck Mia man
Not me but you
Sorry
Mia
M- ah f
You get it
It's not recording..
Hey look my face is back
How bout that?
I don't know what happened
I'm using a different camrea
I will probably switch back for this playthrough
Sorry about that
What do you mean they used to?
What family?
They don't seem like a-
Awh god
You know when it's tight corners
Shit's about to get fucked you know
And
Getting fucked in horror games
Is never a good-
It's never-
It's never good
It's- it's never been good
Except God of War
That was a good thing to get fucked
I liked that one
And HuniePop-
Okay
Hey let's go
Let me guess
It's locked
Isn't it?
Do you have the key?
Just open the door
Oh my god it worked
Okay
Alright
What the fff-
Why?
Awh y- I don't like this enthusiasm
E-001
What?
Uhh what about this one?
Hey creepy dolls
A+ that's just want I wanted right now
HEEY POODIEPIEE
IM A BIG
FAAAAAAAAAAN
CAN I GET A BROFIST?
CAN I GET A BROFIST PLEASE?
HEY Hey give me that brafist
AW HELL YEAH
I FUKIN LOVE YOU
WHEN YOU DO THAT FILTHY FRANK VOICE
DO IT FOR ME PLEASE
Hey how's it going- OH MY GAAAWHHH
MY PUSSEEY
Sorry
Okay
OOUH
Mia?
Aawh it's too bad
That's too bad
I was having really fun with this doll
OH MY GOD PEWDIEPIE YOU CAME BACK FOR ME
AND NOT MIA
OH MY GOD I- uh god dammit
You're so fucking annoying
Heeyy Poodiieepee
Sorry
Jesus
Sorry I'd rather play with dolls
I'm sorry
Okay?
I'm not afraid to admit that
Mia
Mia please
Mia?
Oookay
Aright we're fine
Everything is great
This is great
This is
I think I'll go down instead
I think I just peed a little bit
What the FUCK happened to the weather?
I swear it was
Sunny a second ago
Maybe time changed?
A map
We got a map
Oh fuck this
Okay we're starting to get health
Which is not good
Because that means we're gonna get attacked
Great we can't jump out the window
*BANG BANG BANG*
Who the fuck did that
*continues to knock*
Oh my fucking Lord
Oh my fucking God
God fucking
*still knocking..*
Oh my God no
Who's knockiiing?
Oh my God
*knocking stops*
Oooohh
What do I do?
I don't wanna go down there
Call for help
*phone is out of service*
Aahh
Fuck
I don't have anything to defend myself with
Let's check the map maybe there's a hidden room
Where is the map?
I swear I picked up a map
I'm not ready for this
Oh my god
Mia?
*manly pewds scream*
*screams*
MAMMA MIA
JESUS
NO
UGLY
AWH
BITCH
OH SHIT SHE'S STRONG AS SHIT
MIA
OH
*Random screaming*
WHAT THE FUCK
*More random screaming*
THE FUCK IS WRONG WITH YOU?
MIA
*And more screaming*
MIA YOU CRAZY SON OF A BITCH
WHAT THE FUCK IS WRONG WITH YOU?
MIA
CHILL OUT MAN
I CAME HERE FOR YOOOUU
aah
Can you just
Fuck
Off?
Man
Fuck off.
Okay well you need to ch-
Mia
Ouuhhh
Nooo
We can
Punish you other ways
*Disturbing noises of pewds*
Heyy
Oh that's cool
Can I slit her throat?
I'm sorry but where's the knife?
I- I need to confirm the kill
I need to confirm the fucking kill
Okay this door is open now
Jesus Christ kill that bitch
This was open before
I can't fucking handle this
*Scared shitless pewds*
Oh my god
Stop.
Just stop.
Oh no
I-I think that means I need to run
I think that means-
AN AXE
GET THE FUCK OUTTA MY WAY YOU FUCKING BITCH
IM GONNA FUCKING CHOP THE SHIT OUT OF
WHERE THE FUCK DID YOU YEAH THAT'S RIGHT
Come on bitch
Come on
You wanna-
Awhh thats right I heal
You're fucking not gonna get me
Come on
WILL FUCK YOU UP
YEAH BYEAH Yeah that's right
That's fucking right
*Pewds is happy about the kill*
Hell yeah
*Drinking, burping, gagging noises*
That's fucking right
Survival of the fittest mothafucka
Aw shit mom's calling
I better get that
I better get that call
I bette- I better get that phone call
He-Hello?
OH
I need to end this episode now?
Okay I guess-
I guess I will end the episode now
Thank you for watching
This is amazing so far
I fucking love it
That's really fucking cool
If you're enjoying it as well leave a like
And I'll see you tomorrow with another episode
We're doing this daily so it should be fun
I'm really loving this so far *Burps*
I hope you are as well
Brofist! :D *BTW subscribe to bleachsucc